le futur centre d'entraînement du psg se
dévoile ce vendredi 7 septembre à poissy
la direction parisienne a présenté les
contours du site de 74 hectares qui sera
implanté sur la commune à 25 minutes du
parc des princes
on y retrouvera notamment 17 terrains de
football un dojo et un terrain de
handball la recherche du paris saint
germain aujourd'hui c'est de recréer un
lien avec l'ensemble de ses activités
sportives aujourd'hui nous sommes est
allé sur le territoire parce que ya une
histoire qui s'inscrit de cette manière
là on ouvrit c'est la première fois que
le toutes les activités sportives du
paris saint germain ont par s'implanter
sur un même lieu
la livraison programmée à l'été 2000 21
prévoit également l'implantation d'un
stade de football de 5000 places il y
aura les féminines il y aura l'équipe
réserve
les professionnels vont pouvoir
l'utiliser également de temps en temps
il y aura l'association et d'autres
peut-être gens du territoire qui
pourront occuper et utiliser ce stade le
début des travaux est programmé pour
l'été 2010 9 coût total de l'opération
plus de 220 millions d'euros entièrement
financés par le psg
le prix du transfert du brésilien neymar
dans le club de la capitale